guidance on this issue has just been
published on the scottish government's
website and i want to tell you today
what that guidance says before i do
though i want to stress
at the outset a very important point and
ask you to bear this in mind
i'm talking here about face coverings
made of cloth or other textiles such as
a scarf
i'm not talking about medical grade at
face masks that you would see
health and social care at workers
wearing
the guidance that we are publishing
today firstly makes clear that the most
important step we can all take
to prevent transmission of the virus is
to comply with the current
stay-at-home social distancing and
hygiene rules
face coverings are not i repeat not
a substitute for any of that the
guidance also makes clear that the
evidence on the use of face coverings
is still limited however it recognizes
that there may be some benefit in
wearing a face covering
if you leave the house and enter an
enclosed space
where you will come into contact with
multiple people
and safe social distancing is difficult
for example
on public transport or in shops of
course just now
most shops are closed so right now this
would
apply in particular to food shops
now to be clear the benefit comes
mainly in cases where someone might have
the virus but isn't aware of that
because they're not
experiencing any symptoms and therefore
not isolating completely in line
with the rules so wearing a face
covering in these circumstances
may reduce the chance of that person
transmitting the virus onto
others so the scottish government is now
recommending the use of face coverings
in these limited circumstances as a
precautionary
measure given that the evidence is
relatively weak we're not
at this stage making this mandatory or
suggesting that it will be enforced
though we will be keeping that under
review as we go into future phases of
managing and tackling the pandemic and
of course it's worth bearing in mind
that there are some people
for example people with asthma who might
have very good reasons for choosing
not to cover their mouth and nose when
they're out and about
and we're not recommending the use of
face coverings for children
under the age of two however to repeat
we are recommending that you do wear a
cloth face covering
if you are in an enclosed space with
others where
social distancing is difficult for
example on public
transport or in a shop
but let me emphasize uh the key point
here
which is that you should not really be
in
situations very often like that right
now if you are complying
with the stay at home at rules now the
guidance states that there's no evidence
at this stage to suggest that there are
benefits to wearing a face covering
outside except in unavoidably crowded
situations but again
we are keeping that aspect under review
the guidance also includes some
information on how to safely apply
and wash face coverings when you're
applying
or removing the face covering you should
first wash your hands
and avoid touching your face and after
each time you wear the covering
you must wash it at 60 degrees
centigrade or dispose of it
safely the detail guidance as i've said
is available
on the scottish government's website and
the guidance on the nhs and forum
website will also
be updated very soon but the most
important point i want to stress
again is this one the wearing of facial
coverings is an
extra precaution that you can and we are
suggesting you should take it may do
some good
in some limited circumstances but it is
not
and it must not be seen as a substitute
for the other
rules and guidelines that we have been
stressing and asking you to comply with
in particular anyone with symptoms of
covered 19 and all members of their
household regardless of whether or not
they have symptoms
must self-isolate guidance on that is
already available on the nhs inform
website
and physical distancing hand washing and
respiratory hygiene
covering up coughs with disposable
hankies or
even with your sleeve remain the most
important and
effective measures we can all adopt to
prevent the spread of the virus
so please above all else continue to
follow the rules that we have set out
stay at home except for essential
purposes such as buying food or medicine
or exercising if you do leave the house
you should stay two metres apart from
other people and you should not meet up
with people from other households
and of course you should wash your hands
regularly and
thoroughly i know as i say every day but
every day it becomes
ever more true that sticking to these
rules is really
really difficult but it remains
essential
it is how all of us can help to continue
to slow down the spread of the virus
continue to protect our nhs from being
overwhelmed and continue to save
lives so thank you for sticking with it
and please
continue to do so